on this episode we go to floor 12 have a
hard court Eagles fan and I get a little
Dear Abby ish
[Music]
[Music]
ask Gary B
[Music]
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 143 of the askgaryvee
show I'm on floor 12 woke up some people
I know the Eagles thing is coming from
price and then that's coming this whole
episode I'm actually pissed i sat in
front of him look for my official Jets
Eagles prediction by the way India I'm
two-and-oh on my official predictions on
this season so I'll be coming Friday I
mean at some level some of you gonna
start betting heavily on my skill set
here and I really understand this Jets
team good mood excited to be on 12 your
accent you can you can stand up and give
a little 12 action and what floor 12
portable is loud just the way I like it
alright that's about it super excited
about the comments on the street I will
be doing more of that I almost did that
but I decided to go 12 today and mix it
up a little bit here as we are now
getting to the mid 1 50s the area which
is a pretty epic feat appreciate all
these statement of the days you might
have noticed I'm engaging more on
YouTube finally put it put the app on
the front of my home screen and have
stayed in consistently signed in and
have figured out my cadence on engaging
on YouTube which excites me because so
many of you consume the show on on the
tube and so I will be not just reading
but engaging a little bit more there so
Facebook and that also a lot of you may
not realize this I am constantly on in a
Twitter environment and so for a lot of
you that either don't have a Twitter
account or not as uh using it as often
feel free to ping me there a lot of
engagement with the vaynernation there
so India let's get into the show yeah
the rock you were slow the rock was slow
clinton asks were you ever reckless with
any of your businesses no I don't think
I've ever been reckless with my
businesses hence why they've been
successful I think the only reckless
thing I've ever done which has caused me
non successful ventures is trying to
bite off more than I can chew sometimes
I'm doing way too many things including
now include
always so there's a level of
recklessness within it but on a overall
collective it's not reckless because
it's a net net score game and I win in
business and so no I don't I don't find
myself to be super reckless I think I'm
very much on the offense but there's a
there's a level of practicality I'm very
P&L driven profit and loss that means
cashflow understand they have not to put
myself out of business I think I leave a
lot of profit on the table each year I I
definitely could have a lot more
take-home money from vaynermedia for
example in the last three years but I
continue to invest in my businesses some
may think that's not reckless but maybe
leaving something on the table I look on
look at it as long-term investing not
worrying about short-term cash so now I
don't think I'm a reckless businessman
that's it
no Trouty we put Trouty on the show
Jesus Jesus Browdy okay Trouty asks
first Glenn Beck and now Kim Kardashian
our subscription media sites the next
celeb frontier and will you the answer
is yes will I have one I maybe you know
maybe I mean that's a really interesting
question I mean really fascinating I
know Stefan's holding up the scope right
now I've been really fascinated if I
decided to pay wall the askgaryvee show
or my content what would happen my
intuition is that I would lose 90
percent of my audience but the 10% that
were the most passionate would find a
rationale to pay for it
I do believe pay walls are an intriguing
play if you look at somebody like Howard
Stern went to a radio pay wall I think
until he went back out into America's
Got Talent
he almost disappeared off the face of
the earth he made a lot of money but his
brand took a hit you know for example
I'm gonna assume a lot of you and a lot
of you which are both one of the same
are gonna buy a lot of askgaryvee books
or go to some of my speeches where this
is a jab the content is free but it's a
gateway to brand equity that then kind
of
allows me to to monetize on the back end
I do think that there's a huge
opportunity for paywall
subscription-based I think there's a lot
of money in it I do think a lot of
people are gonna go that route I think
you're gonna see moves by YouTube I
think is we have a long tail of micro
celebrity more people will go there and
so Trouty I do think there is a frontier
in that it is something I debate doing I
tend to believe more in the fact that
I'm not a Beck or a Kardashian so I
don't have as much equity I haven't I
think at super scale when you have broad
awareness you have a better chance of
having meaningful scale and who will pay
I think there's more upside in me
continuing to provide disproportionate
value on this show in my engagement to
keep building up that equity I'm looking
for that depth I don't have that level
of width but yeah I think it's a very
good business model and I do think that
people will pay I do think you know
eight ten twelve twenty dollars a month
for getting what you really want is not
out of the question if you have a lot of
affinity for any content sports
individuals and definitely celebrities
and so yes and and maybe if I'm already
saying on the scope about that
into it other people said that they were
leaving the show they don't want to
watch now they want to watch the show
they're literally leaving the scope
because they want to watch it later I
love that bill via email we're taking
email questions now I don't think we
should open that can of worms in India
well I forward it to so I guess that's
my fault okay well reflect okay go ahead
bill says my girlfriend of four years
and I just broke up you know feeling
really depressed for the last four years
I've had someone to talk to about
literally everything in my life now
that's gone it's hard to believe that
four-year relationship ended in 20
minutes though saving and planning on
proposing her in the next few months and
now that's not gonna happen I feel empty
I feel a void I feel blank got any
advice on how to pick the pieces of my
life back up Jesus you couldn't have
warned me this was coming
well you know I mean if this was my
buddy the first thing I would
desperately try to do is I always feel
like the quickest cure for heartbreak
off a long-term relationship is a scummy
move of hooking up with as many girls as
possible I think it helps in a weird way
I really do I think what I think I
really do think it helps so I think you
know there's only meaningful
relationships and then kind of like the
vanity of relationships when you break
this down and so he's coming from a
meaningful place and I think the vanity
of it all like the one the one micro
positive that guy's cliche we'll think
about then this moment is like well I
can hook up with checks and I think you
have to go all in on that that will last
for about three weeks to three months of
fun and is a is a softener III think you
need to recognize that you got off easy
I don't know if it's Bronx Tale or one
of those gangster movies where the guy
owes the kid 20 the kiddos the kid 20
bucks and he goes and chases them and
then the gangster grabs him and goes you
got off easy
you got you found out he was a scum
bucket for 20 bucks you know brother I
got to be honest with you I think you
got off easy I mean it's a hell of a lot
better that you didn't propose that you
that she was I give her credit she
a lot of people a lot of people mail it
in and get married to people that they
ultimately aren't fully 100% infatuated
in love and for full life and I think
people are mailing in now that divorce
is so easy I think that people just kind
of do it and I actually think in a weird
way you got lucky
and I actually give her a lot of credit
that she after a four and a half year
relationship had the backbone and the
guts to go through a tough process I'm
sure for her as well and so I I actually
think you look at this as a positive I'm
an optimist it's easy for me to say but
I think at some level you you take a
step back and recognize as much as it
hurts now it would have been tougher and
hurt more to unwind after marriage or
what's so difficult for so many after
having children which creates such a
different dynamic and because extremely
difficult and so you know there's not
much I can say that's gonna make it feel
a whole lot better maybe just talking it
out and getting it up the question on
the show the email was asking for it to
be on the show are we just taking
somebody's random oh it just it came in
okay so that's it man I think go hook up
with some chicks to ease the pain for a
few minutes and then and then take a
step back and recognize it's a it's a
positive and and then and try to learn
from the experience and and find out the
qualities you really loved in her and
try to replicate them in in the next
relationship you have and you know maybe
even find the things that you didn't
like as much in her and try to close the
gap and find somebody you love even more
you like that
thanks India JC asks Gary is medium the
new tumblr
what happened to tumblr anyway its
medium the new tumblr I think tumblr is
a more creative outlet visually whereas
medium I think is more creative outlet
in written form tumblr was bought by
Yahoo and anytime you're bought by a
very big media company it's going to
slow down its innovation they need to
integrate still very big app go look in
the Apple your top charts it's still
well entrenched in the top 100
top 125 high so I think they're totally
different I think uh I think they're
both very viable communication platforms
that matter in society
I've the benefit personally of being an
investor both early investor and tumblr
and in medium a big fan of both we spend
a lot of time united jamming in medium
so I don't think it's the new tumblr I
think tumblers still there what happened
to tumblr I think it's a different
animal now and I think depending on how
you want to communicate to the world I
for example I think tumblr has been a
tremendous anonymous platform for people
where they don't have to be themselves
and they can have pseudo names or pseudo
context or you know hot sauce master
tumblr com is a place where you don't
have to be you know necessarily your
name and you can communicate to the
world and I think that really works for
a lot of teenagers and a lot of youth
medium people tend to be themselves on
that platform and has been a gateway for
them to be discovered as great writers
or interesting writers so they're
different and that's my two cents on
those two platforms and if you're
watching this show or listening to the
show and you haven't played with either
platform lately I think one of the great
things about this show is is not just
listening or watching or being
entertained is to take action and so
let's do a little homework assignment
for episode where we 143 what yeah 143 I
challenge you vaynernation to go out and
post three things on tumblr if you
haven't in years if you've never have
and to write three articles on medium if
you haven't in a while or you've never
had I think that to me is the energy as
that we get it closer to episode 200
that I want to start doing which is I
want to create more practitioners than
the amount of people that are listening
and watching to this show right now that
I've never created content for either
platform is stunningly high and I want
to motivate you right this second to go
out and do it because you will learn
from it and it will make you stronger
and better and and that's something I
really want to do out of this show not
just entertain you like that right it
was a good little spin I'm on fire here
Dear Abby practitioner at scale shit's
going down 143
yeah last one Nowell asks how would you
best deal with vultures unethical and
investors would you put them on blast
yeah I mean if they're truly vulture
Asst or unethical investors I'm more
than willing to put them on blast but
something about this question makes me
also want to say make sure that is true
the level of thin skin this in young
first-time businesspeople let me just
say this for the record the audacity
that is running rampant in start-up land
that you're a 22 to 24 year old
entrepreneur with zero proven record and
you're going to the world and you want
them to give you 1 million dollars at a
six million dollar valuation on your
idea pisses me the [ __ ] off and so the
answer is yes to both I would equally
put an entrepreneur that is out of their
goddamn mind and has not contextualized
the insanity of the marketplace that we
live in as I would as an investor who is
being vulture asur unethical and doing
the wrong thing but please recognize
sitting in this ecosystem as I am I have
had a lot of kids come to me and say can
you believe this other investment other
investor that's part of our deal and
when I look at it it is very normal
I would even say 10 years ago soft
negotiating but by the thin skin this of
our society right now feels aggressive
to this 23 year old idea Ricky and so I
would say absolutely I would put them on
blast but boy what I double check that I
don't look like an [ __ ] five years
from now for crying about somebody just
business negotiating and I didn't like
it because I've been so used to the
world giving me eighth place trophies
and mom doing my homework and having no
repercussions for anything for the first
22 years of my life
good show feeling pretty good 12 brought
me some would you stop with that
bullcrap I mean you guys are Owen to
your team's a disaster you should love
them but maybe maybe you should focus on
your work instead of putting up the
football in the background yeah yeah
I hate Eagle fans this week thanks for
watching the show really feeling it
yesterday was a big Jewish holiday so I
was supposed to be checked out but
obviously I was catching up on reading a
lot of the comments and I appreciate it
the energy is real and and I like it and
so lurkers this would be a good time to
come out and say hello floor 12 thank
you for your hospitality statements of
the day really mean a lot to me so
critique the show tell me what you think
about floor 12 tell me what you think
about that last answer and and that's a
scoop you keep asking questions I'll
keep answering them
[Music]
you
[Music]